I
don't you take another step not who I
was expecting the other guy got
reassigned I'm Mia Mia Howard check your
file HQ should have confirmed a few
hours ago
alright heard up
it was 20 years ago today scientists
confirmed we could not reverse the
damage done to the climate officials
have now announced they will present
they will bleed and fear an inside
source destroyed our world and human and
ruthless shooting continues as food
supplies run short this is thought to be
the direct result of government
officials announcing last week that food
rations would ends we destroyed each
other today's peace talks between the
three superpowers broke down and left
the world wondering what the mediate
affects this would have as tensions now
rise to a new level never before
experienced the Strongs of slashes home
surviving the right to change the status
quo the resource war broke out
no one was prized when the world ended
there was only one thing that no one
expected that the world oops one day
start again
can't this thing go any faster
from 7 billion people only 4,000 was
elected to survive the end of the world
4000
do you have to run over them
what it's not like taking [ __ ] and
somehow this guy is one of them
Randall Jefferson the third the center
before the bombs dropped in case a sense
of civic duty wasn't clear those 4,000
descendants of humanity were
cryogenically preserved hidden an
underground bunkers until the surface
was safe
centuries past the surface became safe
the bunkers opened and the descendants
began to rebuild
a one bunker remains sealed largo one
so I volunteered to find out why
hqhq this is search go ahead touch we're
at Oh ones out of gate ready to blow it
off its hinges when you are larger that
on my mark
admit it this feels like you're going
home
let's just get this over with
but if there was even a chance that
anyone was still alive The Descendants
or the janitors watching over them than
any list is worth taking hqhq this is
search we're past the outer gate in the
descent tunnel now what about nothing I
know yeah what you know about that and I
was invited two men searched him a VIP
and me a nobody expendable
Randall few
hqhq remind Donnie a way to take our
time or get those descendants out ASAP
pick origin that good enough for you
one gate down one to go the only
obstacle standing between us and adding
another 108 of humanity's finest to our
ranks at HQ HQ were at the inner gate
please advise HQ HQ do you copy [ __ ]
think you can get us past this that's
why I'm here isn't it I'll see if I can
get this long-range radio working just
hurry up those poor bastards have waited
long enough
the last line of defense against the
outside world I need to hurry up and get
it open
huh I think I got it you waiting for a
written invitation helmets on until we
know what's happening there we can't
take any chances